en cas d'incendiés d'inondations ou de
guerre commence on protéger les oeuvres
d'un musée c'est ce qu'a décidé de
présenter le musée d'archéologie
nationale pendant les journées du
patrimoine
un vrai casse tête quand on sait que le
musée regorge de plus de 3 millions
d'oeuvres les des critères historiques
stylistique scientifique histoire il ya
un sujet rare voilà donc tous ces
critères là les conservateurs vont les
examiner et vont donner un ordre pour
l'évacuation de ces objets est une
priorité c'est dans la salle piette
l'une des plus anciennes salles du musée
et surtout chargé d'histoire que se
déroule cet atelier je trouvais très
drôle de faire donc cette animation dans
la salle piette avec les vénus voilà et
de montrer avec mon collègue comment
conditionne ses oeuvres pour permettre
leur évacuation facilement sachant que
seront pas nous en cas de problème qui
évacueront de ce sont les pompiers le
déplacement de ses oeuvres d'art demande
une véritable logistique la taille le
poids mais aussi l'âge et les
restaurations fait sont à prendre en
compte avant de sécuriser et déplacé une
pièce tout est généralement conditionné
soit en caisse petit ou même très larges
ou des jarres ou des choses beaucoup
plus au delà du pont d'hérault donc tout
ce qui est une sculpture en pierre tout
ça c'est aussi transporté sur palettes
cet atelier organisé uniquement durant
ce week-end a pu ravir le public et même
confirmé l'apprentissage de certains ça
a beaucoup confirmer ce que ce que je
savais ce que j'avais pu voir à travers
mes cours mais c'est vrai que là le fait
qu'ils nous ont montré sur place
vraiment le conditionnement avec le
l'emballage des oeuvres dans les mousses
dans le papier de seebach expérience
nous a montré vraiment tout le matériel
et c'était très intéressant et très très
enrichissant le musée aura trouvé son
public puisque ce week-end 3200
personnes or ont déambulé entre les murs
du château de saint germain en laye